professor gerne und marxist uns jetzt
zugeschaltet der präsident der deutschen
vereinigung für intensiv und
notfallmedizin schönen guten morgen
guten morgen freienfels
55 prozent der intensivstation also nur
noch im eingeschränkten oder teilweise
eingeschränkten betrieb die machen sich
diese einschränkungen in erster linie
bemerkbar
nun wir müssen schon wieder schauen dass
wir unsere reihen geschlossenheit das
heißt wir müssen personal verschieben
wir müssen personal aus dem frei holen
also nach zwei wochenenden auch das
dritte wochenende arbeiten wir müssen
auch schon wieder leider einige
operationen die nicht unbedingt
notwendig sind verschieben damit wir
eben entsprechend alle unsere notfälle
gut und sicher versorgen können wie
dramatisch ist denn die personallage
jetzt aktuell
ja es ist wirklich schon sehr angespannt
ich würde es nicht als dramatisch
bezeichnen aber es ist sehr angespannt
und das ist ungewöhnlich für diese zeit
im sommer wo es normalerweise immer
etwas ruhiger ist ist es eben eigentlich
schon so geführt wie sonst im herbst
oder winter ist
außerdem haben wir gelesen dass es im
moment 2000 betten weniger als noch im
vergleich vor einem jahr gibt wie kommt
dass jetzt ausgerechnet in zeiten der
pandemie die ja wirklich alles andere
als vorbei ist
nun es kommt vielleicht auch gerade
wegen der pandemie wir sind ja nun schon
lange dabei ist zweieinhalb jahre
die personal die personalengpässe hatten
wir auch schon vor der pandemie und das
war für uns gerade auf den
intensivstationen eine besonders
fordernde zeit und viele mitarbeiter
haben ihre arbeitszeit reduziert weil
sie es einfach nicht mehr geschafft
haben und das wird dann summa summarum
dann immer weniger wetten dass heißt im
moment stehen uns wieder im vergleich zu
vor einem jahr 2000 betten wirklich
weniger zur verfügung wir haben doppelt
so viele cholera-patienten viele eigene
mitarbeiter sind auch krank so mal so
warum ist das jetzt schon eine sehr
angespannte situation und wenn ich sie
richtig verstehe rächt sich jetzt auch
dass es schon vor kroner muss man ja
sagen wirklich einen absoluten
pflegenotstand gab
das ist richtig und es wird wirklich
zeit dass wir gemeinsam hier dinge
ändern damit dieser beruf wieder
attraktiv wird damit die menschen wieder
gut und gerne und auch lange in diesem
beruf arbeiten wobei man sagen muss ist
vor allen dingen in der pflege aber es
betrifft am ende des tages alle
berufsgruppen hier müssen wir uns
wirklich kümmern damit wir in den
nächsten jahren auf jeden fall genug
intensiv medizin den bürgerinnen und
bürgern anbieten können welche
forderungen speziell an
bundesgesundheitsminister karl
lauterbach leiten sie denn dann daraus
ab
nun wir stehen ja im ständigen austausch
und haben auch schon letztes jahr unsere
forderungen formuliert da geht es um
unterstützung um
bessere arbeitsbedingungen wir brauchen
letztendlich mehr menschen pro patient
am bett es geht auch um
kompetenzerweiterung
flexible arbeitszeiten es gibt wirklich
sehr konkrete
möglichkeiten wie wir wirklich den beruf
wieder attraktiv machen können es heißt
ja immer omikron seid zwar ansteckender
verlaufe aber deutlich milder und jetzt
eben diese zahlen die es geht doppelt so
viele kurven patienten auf den stationen
wie vor einem jahr woran liegt das
nun ich denke ein wichtiger punkt ist
einfach es gibt so viele erkrankte das
natürlich auch ein gewisser teil
schwerer erkrankt ist das ist im prinzip
eine gewisse statistik hier sind
insbesondere menschen getroffen die
älter sind und die auch vor krank sind
und wenn ganz viele krank sind sind eben
einige auch immer schwer krank und so
mal so machen sind es dann jetzt eben
doppelt so viele wie vor einem jahr und
zum schluss noch ihr blick auf herbst
und winter was erwartet ihr personal was
erwartet die deutschen intensivstation
wenn der sommer schon schwieriger ist
als die anderen vorhergehenden sommer da
wird der herbst wahrscheinlich nicht
leichter werden und die große bitte an
uns alle ist das wir haben ja gelernt
mit der panini eigentlich umzugehen zu
mütze und schal gehört auch die maske
hab so ein winter und die große bitte
lassen sie sich im herbst impfen und
zwar gegen kronau und auch gegen grippe
wir sehen in australien gerade ne große
grippewelle
das sollten wir in deutschland unbedingt
vermeiden das würde die intensiv medizin
ganz stark unterstützen und darum bitten
wie sie professor gernot marx war das
mit seinem appell der präsident der
deutschen vereinigung für intensiv und
notfallmedizin
ganz herzlichen dank für das gespräch
ich danke ihnen